j'en vois que vous dites est handicapé
ça va être quand elle va en campagne
l'accessibilité et sega
pour capter les 22 % des lecteurs de
jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel macron
insiste sur un thème important pour eux
l'écologie la politique que je mènerai
dans les cinq ans à venir sera donc
écologique ou ne sera pas
concrètement il souhaite nommer un
premier ministre directement chargé de
la planification écologique et il promet
d'aller deux fois plus vite sur la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre
comment ça
hier
il ya 48 heures j'ai été contacté pour
me dire vous rencontrer
malheureusement je ne rentrais pas dans
les 48 heures légales pour pouvoir
réserver un piètre malgré l'urgence
puisque ces mecs ont rencontré le
président était une urgence visiblement
pas est un axe
qui peut nous mange que des mois ça
c'est
un automobiliste sort de son véhicule
pour en découdre
il demande au chauffeur de descendre
sans se douter de la mauvaise surprise
qui l'attend
soudain on aperçoit sortir du van quatre
individus déguisés en personnages de
dessins animés
parmi eux bob l'eponge
amy qui
redoutez-vous chez les français un front
anti macron non parce que je dis
explique je vais au contact vous savez
c'est normal il ya des gens qui vous
aiment il ya des gens qui ne vous aiment
pas c'est la vie les quatre individus
s'en prennent à l'automobiliste il le
met à terre et le rouent de coups
scène surréaliste qui fait beaucoup rire
les passagers présents dans le véhicule
du film la caméra
on y voit cents le fils de 6 ans de kim
et du rappeur kanye west jouer avec
l'ipad familiale qu'au soudan
oui il tombe sur une publicité pour la
step de sa maman et la starlette de
fondre en larmes au téléphone avec canet
bon c'est pas très drôle mais quand même
un peu hein comme chaque matin le
ministère publie sur les réseaux sociaux
le bilan quotidien des cas et des
hospitalisations liées à l'épidémie de
covin avec un lien censé diriger les
internautes vers son site web jusque là
il n'y a pas de problème mais jeudi à la
grande surprise de tous le message
habituel renvoyait vers l'un des sites
pour adultes les plus populaires au
monde une maladresse qui aura quand même
mis plus de trente minutes à être
corrigés santé québec s'est finalement
excusé le plaisir à partager en ce
dimanche de pâques avec grand plaisir
mutuel bonne quelle ouverture d'esprit
c'est sale costelle mais ces séries
chassé le partant mais oui on est en fer
blanc les nouilles
j'ai croisé craig david vous avez connu
crécq des les coulisses dans cette
émission et j'étais comme une dingue il
m'avait dit j'ai une banane en trop tu
veux le manche
ça m'avait marqué
tu dis bonjour monsieur vous m'entendez
oui alors je me présente vous devez
venir chez moi normalement j'ai reçu
hier mercredi par dort même pas mardi
enfin je sais plus tient non non c'était
hier vous devez venir y est
allé hop merci bien ce n'est pas une
connerie malheureusement bavois c'est
vrai c'est le bon ok je vais pour me
remettre je bats
mon ego c'est pas pour moi la plupart
des gens en vieillissant prennent
conscience que la vie c'est un chouette
truc vaut pas gaspiller que le stock de
vie il nous reste à partir de 50 60 fort
n'est plus limité et qu'il faut
l'ajouter à fond
bas peut pas m'aider